oh my goodness I played you I guess you
might say forever
probably about 1931 is when I first
started maybe five years of costumey
that I've been playing hockey I'm mark
circuit I'm the oldest ice hockey player
in the world I'm 95 years old hope to be
96 on July 18th I'm still playing hockey
three times a week I get up at 6:00 in
the morning I do my situps my push-ups
and a few other things that kind of
loosen me up and then I'm ready to go
yeah and when you live about a mile away
but I do drive down by myself and it's
funny but I'm usually the last one there
I'm the one that lives closest the group
consists mostly of some former
firefighters and also of course the
current one so there's quite a different
mixture there I think about my age and
once a while I say to myself well you
know you're only 59 you're not 95 why's
your turn the numbers are on you make
myself feel better
my love for hockey is is hard to explain
you're Seaton with the puck you're
shooting the puck you're trying to take
the puck away from the other guy there's
so many different things you're doing
this it just keeps you going there
everybody's got a role I'll keep
business
keep finishing it I'm going to do a
little bit better
I'll try off get the clothes cute put
this out there or doing something right
[Music]
there is a greatest bunch of guys I've
ever played with he sent me up all the
time and sometimes it gets to a point
where I'm almost embarrassed that I'm
not scoring more because they're always
giving me the puck a group of the
players right after hawk eagle come over
to my home and we sit down in the
kitchen and discuss who did what on the
ice and so on and so forth at my age is
a wonderful way of being connected with
younger people and I think that's very
important for for an older person I'm so
fortunate that it gives me a chance to
be involved this is really the best
thing has ever happened